5 gilet jaune devant la justice
aujourd'hui à lors du huitième samedi de
manifestation c'était au mois de janvier
vous avez forcé l'entrée du ministère de
l'ancien porte parole du gouvernement
benjamin griveaux à l'aide d'un
transpalette de chantier près de deux
ans plus tard et après deux renvois
le procès a donc le nous sommes en
direct du tribunal de paris avec notre
reporter belgique
bonjour bassem alors ce sont quatre
hommes et une femme qui sont jugés pour
plusieurs dégradations et notamment pour
le vol du chariot élévateur
effectivement amira le procès a commencé
dans les alentours de 13h30 ici au
tribunal de grande instance de paris
quatre hommes une femme comparaissent
pour vol et détériorations je vous
rappelle c'était pendant l'acte et 8
comme vous venez de dire c'était en
janvier 2019
certes un gilet jaune un vol d'un
fenwick pour s'introduire à l'intérieur
du ministère le ministère de benjamin
griveaux à l'époque porte-parole du
gouvernement au sein de cette salle
d'audience qui se trouve juste derrière
moi pas moins d'une quinzaine de vidéos
ont été présentées au tribunal des
vidéos dans lesquelles on voyait cette
scène avec le fenwick le ministère et
surtout cette scène du fenwick dans les
rues de paris donc ils sont arrivés
progressivement à la barre répondait aux
questions de la présidente leur
motivation et le contexte dans lequel
ces actes ont eu lieu tous ont répondu
ne pas savoir que c'était un ministère
tous ont répondu être dans l'effet de
foule et dans l'euphorie du moment
certains même ont déclaré qu'ils étaient
alcoolisés c'est le cas de deux
individus qui conduisait ce phénix
tous regrettent leurs actes selon leurs
dires à la barre et puis le tribunal
essaye de comprendre les motivations le
parcours de ces gels et jaune 5 kg le
jaune de région parisienne et du nord
comparaissent pour ces dégradations et
puis on a pu observer dans les
différentes vidéos que je fais lui
continué sa course sa course qui a
terminé dans la vitrine de la banque
société générale
et puis dégradation à la banque à la bnp
pardon ces deux banques là ce sont aussi
dans le dossier sur le même dossier que
le fenwick ce procès doit durer deux
jours jusqu'à demain demain pour savoir
éventuellement pourquoi
de tels les actes lors de cet acte 8d
gilet jaune
il encourt jusqu'à dix ans de prison et
150 mille euros damende donc on verra la
suite à partir de demain
merci bassem pour toutes ces précisions